bah ouais alors attention
[Rires]
à côté attention si personne ne touche
la télé
qui gagne le premier
duo finalement c'est pas bonjour
Géraldine autre chose
on s'échapper là
attends attends
[Applaudissements]
sur le match merci Mathieu en plus
j'étais très déçu très triste d'abord tu
bravo
a bien joué quand même allez Guillaume
contre Gilles les deux qualifiés ces
gens Marie et Géraldine Guillaume contre
Gilles
s'il vous plaît non attention
calme-toi Gilles tu es en train de
devenir fou
il a touché le tunnel il était
limitées
s'il vous plait s'il vous plaît allez
gagner aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
attention donc Mokhtar qualifié on aura
donc un premier match Jean-Marie contre
Sophie en quart de finale
a gagné même si c'est la dernière fois
commencer l'émission
Guillaume contre Guillaume contre
Jean-Michel
[Applaudissements]
première demi-finale
il y a Sophie
contre Guillaume Jean-Michel
[Applaudissements]
Jean-Michel a gagné 2006 Jean-Michel
demi-finale
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci
tu es malade
ne le faites pas chez vous Les Chéries
c'est fait ici par des professionnels
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il y avait rien à gagner donc je te dis
la vérité c'était juste pour faire les
cons hein
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça y est c'est la guerre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis trompé c'est n'importe quoi
c'est n'importe quoi c'est n'importe
quoi